when did it start
about two years ago two and a half years
ago yeah
and what did what did you notice
well I started to lose a hearing in my
left ear and it eventually or it's at
this moment it's
you know I think eight percent Hearing
in that ear really uh I'm hopeful that
something can be
something can be done but uh but I'm
starting to
get used to the fact that maybe nothing
nothing could be done
I can still hear well enough to play
guitar and write yeah but I can't hear
well enough to play with
five or six musicians
and sing and in a big space
with a lot of noise it's it's uh
it's a confusion
maybe that's fine maybe it's a maybe
there's something to be
learn from that or what do you think
that would be
I have to see what it is acceptance of
you know less you have less and you have
to make do with less
that would be true for everybody yeah
so it could be it could be that the most
frustrating thing is
I really took it for granted that I
could do this thing which is here very
well hear sound very well
and uh I wonder when when it went away I
was
yeah I was frustrated I was angry
and I still I could go there but
there's no there's no use to go there's
no use to go there I imagine that must
be a complicated conversation that
you've had to go through in your own
head
about all that it is
yeah and you probably feel different
about it different days
no I feel pretty much the same about it
which is like uh you know I'm just not
not happy about it you did play Newport
last summer yeah things got worse since
then yeah
then I could still hear enough if I had
speakers over here but now I can't yeah
do you think that might be kind of your
last big performance
well I hope not yeah
I hope not I really wanted to do the to
perform the seven Psalms yeah
and possibly I I could because it's a
simple piece with a guitar yeah and uh
kind of percussion instruments so it's
that's possible even though I wrote and
played the guitar on this I I couldn't
even if a hearing was
fine I I couldn't play it and sing it at
the same time at the guitar is too
complicated for me to
be able to concentrate on My Singing and
telling storytelling and play this so I
need somebody else so I'll try that this
week and see what I see what I find out
I haven't given up hope but uh but I'm
prepared if uh to accept that I might
not be able to